[Music]
over in britain the leader of the uk
independence party or ukip gerard batten
has recently grasped the third rail of
politics in the west
venturing where no other british or
american politician has yet dared to go
according to sky news baton has linked
islam to the industrialized sexual
exploitation of girls across the country
this connection ought to be blazingly
obvious but it isn't
and the fact that there is even any
controversy over baton's remarks
indicates how much of a fix britain and
the west in general
is really in today this is what battens
said
the ideology of the religion does
actually traditionally throughout its
history
make sex slaves legitimate their prophet
had sex slaves
this was too much for sky news presenter
gillian joseph
who has no doubt spent years studying
the quran and sunnah
but when joseph challenged baton baton
refused to back down
declaring it's in the hadith and the
quran it's a tradition
that that's okay to do that people take
their prophet as the model for all time
and the perfect human being so if he did
something then it's okay for other
people to do it
to the inevitable charge that baton is
anti-muslim he responded in advance
saying this the problem is with the
ideology not individuals
i have never attacked individuals i
always talk about the ideology
and the ideology is the problem
joseph claimed that baton was attacking
the entire religion of islam
how when where but to that baton
responded
it does allow their followers to take
sex slaves who are not of the same
religion
it is no good telling me and the world
it doesn't happen
because everybody knows it does happen
it is predominantly
people who follow that religion who are
causing this problem
on a national scale which is the
industrialized
sexual exploitation for money and for
their own perverted purposes
that happens to be a fact determined as
are all
establishment media journalists to
defend islam at all costs
and absolve it of all responsibility for
the crimes done in its name
and in accord with its teachings gillian
joseph then brought up the catholic
church and its pandemic and ever-growing
pedophilia scandal
baton was ready for this he said i'm
happy to condemn pedophilia and child
abuse and sexual abuse
wherever it occurs it is reprehensible
whoever commits it
now why is stating the obvious that the
rape gangs that have exploited
and destroyed thousands of british girls
have been
overwhelmingly made up of muslims even
remotely controversial
because the denial and willful ignorance
regarding the muslim rape gang's
connection to islam
is not universal in britain today but to
deny this is to deny an ever-growing
mountain of evidence
one survivor of a muslim rape gang in
the uk said that her rapists would quote
the quran to her
and believed that their actions were
justified by islam
and there is indeed an islamic
theological foundation for this behavior
the quran teaches that infidel women can
be lawfully taken for sexual use
its allowance for a man to take captives
of the right hand
see chapter 4 verse 3 chapter 4 verse 24
chapter 23 verses 1 to 6 chapter 33
verse 50
and chapter 70 verse 30. the quran says
this
o prophet tell your wives and your
daughters and the women of the believers
to bring down over themselves of their
outer garments
that is more suitable that they will be
known and not be abused
and ever is allah forgiving and merciful
that's chapter 33 verse 59 the
implication there
is that if women do not cover themselves
adequately with their outer garments
they may be abused and that such abuse
would be justified
but you simply can't say this in
shattered
staggering demi britain today when labor
mp sarah champion wrote something far
less politically incorrect than what
baton has said now
she said this britain has a problem with
british pakistani men raping and
exploiting white girls
labor expelled her from the shadow
cabinet
sarah champion was axed from the shadow
cabinet even though she repeated
the politically correct fictions about
the rape gangs having nothing to do with
islam
even as she dared to note that the
perpetrators were pakistani
she said the real frustration is that i
don't know what motivated these gangs
other than being of pakistani heritage
what is the commonality
it might be that they went to the same
school people sloppily call them muslims
but are they muslims
i don't know they could be pakistani
christians
no they couldn't the names of the
perpetrators alone
indicate that they're muslims there are
no pakistani christian rape gangs
it is a shame that sarah champion has
received death threats for her tepid
and half true remarks but she is
actually an indication of the terrible
state britain is in today
everyone is willfully blind and one
person with one eye is lauded as far
seeing
so gerard batten has now stated what no
one else dares to say in britain today
for fear of committing political suicide
and britain is so far gone at this point
that baton's hope of having a political
future may be as dim
as the prospect of britain surviving as
a free society
i'm robert spencer shulman fellow for
the david horowitz freedom center
and director of ghodwatch this video has
been brought to you by
the center for security policy